let's continue with the 30-60-90
triangles so just to review what we just
learned or hopefully learned at minimum
what we just saw is if we have a
30-60-90 triangle and once again
remember this only applies to 30-60-90
triangles this angle is 30 this is 60
and if I were to say the hypotenuse is
of length H we learned that the side
opposite the 30-degree angle and this is
the shortest side of the triangle is
going to be H over 2 or 1/2 times I
hypotenuse and we also learned that the
longer side or the side opposite the
60-degree side is equal to the square
root of 3 over 2 times H so let's do a
problem where we use this information
let's say I had this triangle right here
it's a 90 degree triangle let's say that
this is 30 degrees and we could also
figure out if that's 30 this is 90 that
this is also 60 degrees and let's say
that the hypotenuse is 12 the length is
12 and we know that the hypotenuse
because it's opposite the right angle
what is this side right here well is
this side opposite the 60-degree angle
or is it opposite the 30-degree angle
it's the 30 degree angle that opens into
it right
I drew this triangle a little bit
different on purpose the 30 degree angle
opens up into this side and it's also
the shortest side as we learned that the
side opposite the 30-degree angle is
half the hypotenuse so hypotenuse is 12
this would be 6 and this side which is
opposite the 60-degree side is equal to
the square root of 3 over 2 times
hypotenuse so it's the square root of 3
over 2 times 12 or it's just equal to 6
square roots of 3 another interesting
thing is of course the longer non
hypotenuse side is square root of 3
times longer than the short side I don't
want to confuse you too much let's do
another one let's say
let's say this is 30 degrees it's our
right triangle and I were to tell you
that this side right here is 5 what is
the length of the side well first of all
let's figure out what we have 5 is which
side oh if this is 30 degrees we know
that this is going to be 60 degrees so 5
is opposite the 60 degree side and X is
the hypotenuse since X is opposite the
90-degree side it's also the longest
side of the right triangle so we know
from our formula that v is equal to the
square root of 3 over 2 times the
hypotenuse which in this example is X
and now we just solve for X and we can
multiply both sides by the inverse of
this coefficient so if you just multiply
2 times the square root of 3 times
square root of 3 and then 2 times the
square root of 3 oops you can ignore
this we get 10 over the square root of 3
here and of course this 2 cancel out
with this 2 this square root of 3 cancel
out of the square root 3 is equal to X
and now if you if you watch the last
couple of presentations you realize that
this could be the right answer but we
have a square root of 3 in the
denominator which people don't like
because it's an irrational number in the
denominator and I guess we could have a
debate as to why that might be bad so
let's rationalize this denominator so we
say X is equal to 10 over the square
root of 3 to rationalize this
denominator we can multiply the
numerator and the denominator by square
root of 3 right because as long as we
multiply the numerator denominator by
the same thing it's like multiplying by
1 so this is equal to 10 square roots of
3 over the square root of 3 times square
2 3 well that's just 3 so x equals 10
square roots of 3 over 3 this hypotenuse
I know I confused you and of course so
if this is 10 square root of 3 over 3
right that's not news we know that the
30-degree side right this is 30 degrees
we know the 30-degree side is half of
that so it's 5 square root of 3 over 3
anyway I think that might give you a
sense of the 30-60-90 triangles I think
you might be ready now to try some of
the level 2 Pythagorean theorem problems
have fun